they slipped what to do merged first if
anyone thinks that ceasing tank is an
attacking oil infrastructure can in any
way affect cooperation between Russia
and our Arab friends Saudi Arabia and
the UAE they can undermine or break down
our cooperation with OPEC plus then they
profoundly wrong doc we need a big
country like Iran which has existed on
its territory for thousands of years has
its own interests Persians and Iranians
have lived here for centuries and we
should respect those interests which is
new answer you need to have dialogue to
understand each other to puzzle out all
the nuances intricacies and issues
without dialogue you cannot solve any
problem that is why I think I can share
the concerns of the UAE and Saudi Arabia
but in the case of bilateral issues it
is up to them to resolve them which
enlist you here all the forces deployed
illegitimately inside any sovereign
state in this case syria must leave this
is true for everyone if Syria's new
legitimate government chooses to say
that they have no more need for Russia's
military presence this will be just is
true for Russia right now we are
discussing this openly with all our
partners including Iran in Turkey we
spoke about it with our American
partners many times and I will be open
with you as I have been with my
counterparts Syria must be free from
other states military presence and the
territorial integrity the Syrian Arab
Republic must be completely restored
you work for Russia today don't you well
it is because of people like you that
Russia we accused of meddling in the
election
[Music]
you